learn about API security with this
course that is tailored to address the
pivotal PCI DSS 4.0 requirements PCI DSS
stands for payment card industry data
security standard it is a set of
security standards designed to ensure
that all companies that accept process
store or transmit credit card
information maintain a secure
environment as the PCI standard takes a
definitive turn to Spotlight API
security for the first time
understanding its intricacies becomes
crucial for businesses dive into decode
what DSS 4.0 means for your organization
why apis are now in the Limelight of
attackers and gain invaluable insight
into ensuring compliance equip yourself
with knowledge best practices and stay a
step ahead in safeguarding your
operations this course was developed by
Dan Barona who has 20 years of
experience in cyber security hello free
code Camp community and welcome to app
SEC University and this course on API
security for PCI compliance my name is
Dan Barona one of the co-founders here
at appc University and for the next hour
you'll learn all about the new PCI DSS
4.0 and what it and what requirements it
has for API security I also invite you
to check out all our free courses on
appek university.com including a
Hands-On course on API pen testing an
introductory course on API security
fundamentals this course on PCI
compliance sence as well as one on the
OAS API top 10 API documentation and
more to come all the courses on our site
include quizzes to assess your knowledge
and if you complete everything and pass
the final quiz we'll issue you a
certificate and badge to recognize your
accomplishment which you can also
display on your LinkedIn profile thanks
again for watching and I hope you enjoy
this
[Music]
course
hi and Welcome to our course on API
security for PCI compliance in 2022 PCI
released version 4.0 of the data
security standard and it's the first
major update in the last 10 years A lot
has changed since then not just in the
standard but in the world of of apis if
you think back to 2013 when 3.0 came out
Google was just releasing their glass
product we were on the iPhone 5
Instagram was just adding video to their
platform and the OAS Community was six
years away from releasing an API
security top 10 adoption of apis was at
a fraction of where it is today and all
Industries have emerged around apis
particularly in fintech and e-commerce
companies that rely entirely on apis and
it's hard to imagine any credit card
transaction taking place today that is
not using API somewh where in the
chain and apis don't even appear in 3.0
of the DSs standards at all um but
feature prominently in 4.0 the goal of
this course is to introduce you to the
changes in 4.0 specifically as they
apply to apis and not only to show you
how to achieve compliance but to elevate
your security posture overall I hope you
enjoy the
course let's Dive Right In and review
what we're going to be covering in this
course we're going to start with the
basics why are we even talking about API
Security in the context of PCI and DSs
how are apis even relevant and why
should we care for those who are new to
PCI we'll do a very brief introduction
uh of the PCI standard itself follow
that up with a review of the DSs data
security standard and examine what's new
in 4.0 what's changed and when you need
to comply and then we'll get into the
core of the course here reviewing the
DSs 4.0 standards uh and requirements in
detail we'll be unpacking individual
sections of 4.0 understanding what the
requirements are the best practices and
exploring what this means for apis and
how to keep your organization safe as
always we'll wrap it up with some best
practices and dos and don'ts that you
can start implementing today we'll
feature some quizzes as we go along and
a final quiz as well and if you complete
the whole course we'll be pleased to
send you a certificate in badge to
demonstrate your
achievement but first let me introduce
myself uh I'm your instructor for this
course my name is Dan barahona I've been
in the cyber security industry for over
20 years held lots of different roles uh
spanning Marketing sales products uh
holding leadership roles at places like
qualis hpn arcite anomaly and over here
at appy SEC from an education
perspective I earned engineering degrees
from rinier in Cornell University before
doing an MBA over at University of
Michigan I'm the co-founder here of
appek University and I really love to be
in touch so if you want to look me up
and connect with me on LinkedIn or you
can email me anytime at danais
University happy to get your messages
questions feedback anything we can do to
continue to grow this appc University
site thanks so
much let's kick things off by
understanding why API security is such
an important topic and why it's so
relevant to
PCI and there are three important
Dynamics happening now with
apis the first is that apis are
exploding we've known this for years and
it just continues you've probably seen
the statistic that over
83% of all internet traffic now is API
based it's a study from aami they
analyzed all their Network traffic and
discovered this incredible prevalence of
of API sourced traffic look at the API
calls 100 billion open banking API calls
this year and expected to grow by 5x
over the next 5 years to to 500 billion
there's really no end in sight of the
adoption of apis and that's thanks to
just the sheer value and benefit that
these apis provide and they're powering
virtually everything every e-commerce
transaction our medical devices our
connected cars you can lock and unlock
start and stop engines through apis
they're really powering virtually
everything but apis are also under heavy
attack the stats are really quite
staggering 40 to 75 billion dollars a
year in cyber loss related to apis for
years Gartner the the analyst firm has
been predicting that by
2022 apis would become the most frequent
attack Vector I think that has been
borne out and continues to be true I
have another course API security
fundamentals if you want to learn more
about specific breaches we go into a lot
of detail there and explore how apis
were exploited so recommend you check
out that course if you're interested but
the third Dynamic is API security our
apis are seriously UND secured and if
you just look at testing Alone um this
report from stateof ais.com looks at all
of the testing we do on apis and only 4%
of that effort is focused on security uh
and there's a reason for this um how we
build applications as fundamentally
changed but security is still keeping up
I want to share some thoughts from a
recent Gartner report that really nailed
the challenges and the changes happening
in application development and security
this comes from a hype cycle report on
application security that Gartner
published in July 2023 some of the key
trends are that we're now developing
apps more quickly in more agile ways
we're relying more and more on
developers to secure the code to
integrate security into their
applications
and we've changed how we deploy and
operate our applications with things
like Cloud native strategies and and
these are challenging our traditional
and established approaches to
application development and and
provisioning and deployment um however
our existing application security
controls uh have not kept up and they've
they've become less effective um dionio
from from Gartner summarizes it well API
attacks have resulted in a stream of
data Brees and Dev SEC Ops teams have
increasingly become interested in API
testing and security however our
traditional a Tools application security
testing tools were not originally
designed to test for some of the unique
types of vulnerabilities associated with
typical attacks against apis and his
point is really spoton API attacks are
fundamentally different and let's
examine
why so organization have long used tools
like sast and dast static and dynamic
application security testing Solutions
and these are very mature well-known
tools that look for pore coding
practices injection flaws cross-site
scripting things like uh csrf cross-site
uh request forgery ssrf server side
request forgery misconfigurations and
the like um these tools are looking for
common vulnerabilities common flaws uh
that might exist in your app
applications but if you look at the
breaches that uh successfully exploit
apis and result in the losses of
hundreds of millions of Records this is
not what's causing those breaches it's
not injections it's not cross-site
scripting API breaches exploit something
different typically business logic flaws
or gaps in authorization or weak
authentication and the like and if you
want to keep up on this there's a great
site API city.io where they capture
these types of events and exploits and
breaches and you'll see how API breaches
happen just doesn't look like our
traditional web application attacks and
this graphic down below reinforces the
point um our web scanners for the most
part are scanning at the UI layer mobile
UI web UI and there are two issues with
this approach first we've been relying
on the UI layer for too long to do more
than presentation the UI layer is also
providing security it's filtering what
data users can see what actions they can
take what buttons they can
press and this is a problem the UI
should really be about presentation not
about
security and the reason why is that uis
are powered by apis and attackers are
going to go right around your UI
straight to the API and at the API level
you don't have the benefit of this UI
and the filtering and the controls that
it's providing so if an attacker Can
Dream up a request for an API they can
send it and if your back-end app logic
doesn't know to block those requests
they'll get executed and that's how API
breaches happen again we have a whole
course focused on this topic the API
security fundamentals course where you
can learn a lot more on
this no API security course would be
completed without a mention of the oosp
API security top 10 the oosp is the open
web application security project it's a
community that has produced truly
foundational application security guides
and is famous for its top 10 lists in
2019 oasp added a dedicated top 10 for
API security which differed quite a bit
from their web app top 10 these lists
are widely considered to be industry
standards for how to secure your
applications and in
2023 the OAS Community released an
updated version of the API top 10 which
you can see here there have been some
changes some additions and deletions and
some items remain the same the top two
are still at the top and for good reason
the vast majority of API breaches
violate one or both of these items
number one is broken object level
authorization also known as Bola and it
refers to the ability of of say one user
being able to access another user's data
through an API and there are many
examples of these which we cover in some
of our other courses number two is
broken authentication which is also a
frequent cause of breaches many times
API endpoints are left open with no
authentication uh with organizations
assuming these endpoints won't be
discovered you should always assume they
will be discovered as attackers uh will
try their best to find these endpoints
uh and you should protect all endpoints
with security regardless of whether they
are documented published internal or
external one of the new entries on the
OA top 10 is number six unrestricted
access to sensitive business flows and
this is the first time that oasp has
referenced business logic specifically U
recognizing the opportunities to exploit
logic flaws in your applications to
access sensitive data and you'll see
that this concept of business logic
appears in DSS 4.0 as well there's a
specific requirement that we'll cover to
test business logic of your applications
and your apis in order to find any
vulnerabilities we've got a whole course
dedicated just to the oasp API security
top 10 which you can also find on our
website if you're new to PCI let's have
a very quick review of what it's all
about
PCI stands for payment card industry and
the primary goal is to safeguard
sensitive card holder data and maintain
trust in the payment card
industry until PCI was created the five
major credit card Brands Visa Mastercard
American Express discover JCB all had
their own security standards and in 2004
they all got together formed the
PCI and created a unified set of
security requirements starting with with
defining what data needs to be protected
which you can see below data like the
primary account number or pan card
holder name expiration
verification stripe and Chip data pins
and more now PCI is not a law there's no
government enforced regulation here but
it is a contractual obligation that
applies to any entity that stores
transmits or processes credit card
transactions you can see the time line
of PCI here on the right it was launched
in 2004 in 2006 and 2009 we saw major
credit card breaches at TJ Maxx where 45
million uh records were breached and at
Heartland payment system where 130
million records were breached which
really reinforced the criticality of PCI
and led to the release of DSs 2.0 in
20110 3.0 in
2013 and 4.0 another 9 years later in
2022 within PCI there are a number of
different security standards and you can
see some of them here below each focuses
on a different aspect of payment card
transactions for example there are
standards on encryption on pin Security
on point of sale devices the one
standard that affects virtually every
organization that's covered by PCI
organizations that store process or
transmit credit card transactions is DSS
the data security standard and that's
what we'll be focusing on for the rest
of this
course so let's start at the top with
the data security standard throughout
this course I will use direct excerpts
from the DSs documentation itself you
can find the documentation and much more
in the PCI document library at pcst
standards.org
let's focus first on the six primary
goals of DSs running secure networks and
systems protecting account data finding
and fixing vulnerabilities control who
can access what testing and monitoring
and maintaining a security policy those
six goals are further broken down into
12 DSS requirement categories which you
can see here everything from updating
default passwords to controlling user
access to testing apps for
vulnerabilities is covered here each
requirement provides a detailed
description how to test for compliance
and guidance on purpose and best
practice we are going to focus on
requirement six develop and maintain
secure systems and software here is
where the DSs specifies how
organizations must develop test and
operate secure
applications next let's dig into what's
new in 4.0 DSS 4.0 is a huge update to
the data security standard as you can
see the requirement stock itself grew by
over 2 and a half FX to 360 Pages the
PCI security standards Council has
outlined four primary goals for the new
4.0 standard starting with of course
continuing to meet the security
standards and security needs of the
payment industry promoting the concept
of security being a continuous process
not a one-time or periodic
assessment adding flexibility for
different methodologies and recognizing
that not all organiz ations do things
the same way so DSS 4.0 provides some
options for compliance in certain
requirements and finally to enhance
validation methods being more explicit
about what compliance looks like and how
to assess it now what's especially
noteworthy with respect to apis is that
in 3.0 there was no mention of apis and
apis appear in multiple sections
throughout requirement 6 of the DSs 4.0
and even where apis aren't explicitly
mentioned they still are very relevant
and one way to think about this is if
your apis are in scope for your
attackers then they ought to be in scope
for your Security Programs too let's
look at what the compliance timeline
looks like for 4.0 real quick the 4.0
standard was published in q1 in Q2 of
2022 and as of Q2 2022 organizations
could begin certifying against the 4.0
standard that's the beginning of the
transition period that you see here on
the timeline the deadline for 4.0
compliance is March 31 2024 meaning all
organizations must comply with the DSs
4.0 requirements by the end of
q124 there are a few requirements that
the DSs has provided a longer compliance
period uh those are are all required by
March 31
2025 um I'll flag those where relevant
in the coming slides and if you want to
learn more about any of this um here are
a few useful resources I've shared the
links in the course
materials this brings us to the core of
this course reviewing the specific
requirements in DSS 4.0 and what they
mean for apis we'll be reviewing about a
dozen sections in the data security
standard mostly from requirement six and
examining in detail what is being
required and how to achieve it in each
case I'll show you the actual text from
the DSs document itself discuss how this
requirement applies to apis and provide
best practices to comply and keep your
API secure so let's get
started starting with
2.2.7 which states all non-c console
administrative access is encrypted using
strong cryptography
I bring this one up as this requirement
explicitly mentions apis in fact it's
the first time the data security
standard has flagged API specifically in
this case the requirement highlights
that encrypted admin console access is
required not just for browser based uis
but also for application programming
interfaces or apis so it's a pretty
straightforward requirement and of
course all our application communication
should be done over encrypted
channels
now we'll get into the core of DSs 4.0
which is requirement 6 developing and
maintaining secure systems and software
here you see a number of sub
requirements which we'll get into but
one term you'll see throughout
requirement six is bespoke in custom
software this refers to any custom code
developed by your organization or
provided to you by another party and
this is subject to these DSS
requirements specifically if that
software stores processes or transmits
account data or could impact the
security of account data this definition
encompasses apis so if your bespoken
custom software incorporates apis those
are in scope so as we review the
requirements throughout DSS 4.0 if it
applies to your custom developed
application it applies to those apis as
well here at the bottom PCI has provided
guidance that for custom software
numerous vulnerabilities can be avoided
by a applying software life cycle
processes and secure coding techniques
organizations should strive to create a
culture of security across the
application development team
understanding application risks writing
more secure code testing for
vulnerabilities and fixing ahead of
production moving ahead to section
6.2.1 bepoke and custom software are
developed securely as follows based on
industry standards or best practices for
security
development uh in accordance with the
pcidss and incorporating consideration
of information security issues during
each stage of the software development
life cycle that's the requirement of 621
further the DSs standard instructs
organizations to understand how
sensitive data is handled by the
application to inform how to protect the
data the implication for apis here is
pretty clear PCI wants organizations to
bake in sec as early as possible in the
creation of custom code or shift left
security as you may have heard it
stating that DSS requirements must be
considered When developing software by
Design rather than trying to retrofit
the software later to achieve this
requirement organizations need to ensure
application developers are aware of the
API security risks and can create and
test code to mitigate those
risks where 6.2 2.1 calls for
organizations to utilize industry best
practices for secure application
development 6.2.2 goes a step further
and mandates training for developers it
states software development Personnel
working on bspoke and custom software
must be trained at least every 12 months
and that training needs to be one
relevant to their job function and
development languages two include secure
software design and coding techniques
and three train on the use of testing
tools for detecting vulnerabilities in
software as organizations develop
applications with apis engineer teams
must be trained on API related risks as
well as best practices for avoiding API
exposures and vulnerabilities
organizations should arm development
teams with API focused security training
such as what we provide on appc
University the standard also points to a
need for vulnerability detection and
testing custom software for apis
organizations need to begin or expand
their security testing and as we saw
earlier only 4% of all API testing is
focused on security new API security
testing tools do exist that will
automate API testing and give you
continuous assessment organizations
can't rely solely on manual testing or
once or twice a year pen testing and
finally development teams need to be
trained on these tools and how to use
them to find abilities before they ever
get to production I'd like to point out
that APC University makes our courses
compatible with internal Learning
Management Systems so if you'd like to
provide our courses to your colleagues
and employees within your LMS we can
help feel free to get in
touch section 6.2.3 continues the theme
of looking for and addressing
vulnerabilities in code he spoken custom
software must be reviewed prior to being
released in production or to customers
to identify and correct potential coding
vulnerabilities these code reviews need
to look for new and emerging
vulnerabilities and traditionally new
and emerging vulnerabilities refers to
things like zero days or other newly
discovered
vulnerabilities these vulnerabilities
are most likely to be related to
thirdparty libraries and apis that you
use in your applications so make sure to
keep updated on any vulnerability
reports a critical best practice though
when using third party API is to trust
nothing your application should not
assume that the data coming back from
external providers is legitimate check
all responses to make sure that it fits
with what you're expecting for example
if your app uses a third-party API to
normalize say physical addresses make
sure you don't accept responses that
could be malicious like URLs or strings
with slashes or anything that doesn't
look like an
address and the final item in the good
practice section is especially relevant
checking for logical vulnerabilities
this is perhaps the most dangerous type
of flaw in applications if there is a
logic flaw in your app that flaw will
get exposed via the API allowing an
attacker to exploit it your custom
software must be analyzed and tested
toine these logic
flaws this section of requirement 6 is
one of the most substantial in terms of
testing for vulnerabilities and I like
to think of 624 as the oos section of
requirement six it mandates the use of
software engineering techniques to
prevent or mitigate common software
attacks and vulnerabilities in bspoke
and custom software so this section
details a whole lot of attack vectors
that need to be considered things like
injections authentication exploit
bypassing authorization cross- site
scripting cross- site request forgery
security misconfiguration and more all
of these covered by the oos top 10 it
also explicitly flags apis as an
interface that must be considered when
addressing these risks your testing
programs must include apis not just the
web and mobile app
interfaces 624 also reinforces the
concept of business logic attacks that
we just learned about in the prior
section and the need to examine your own
application functionality and consider
not only how your apps are meant to be
used but critically how your apps might
be abused for example and here's a real
world example there was an attacker who
exploited an API on a crypto trading
platform to sell his ethereum stock as
Bitcoin the API allowed a user to
overwrite what asset they were trading
and sell it as something else a great
example of a logic flow web scanners and
Pen testers regularly test uis for
injection vulnerabilities and that must
be expanded to include testing at the
API layer in the last call out box here
you'll see developers should be familiar
with different types of vulnerabilities
and potential attacks and use measures
to avoid potential attack vectors When
developing code the need for security
training for developers repeats
throughout requirement 6 again the API
security fundamentals course offers
great training for developers and others
who need to understand API
risks 6.3.1 covers vulnerability
management and sets the requirements for
how organizations need to operate a VM
program to start security teams need to
have access to vulnerability information
there are plenty of vulnerability
databases and the industry standard
source for vulnerabilities is the cve
database hosted by miter you can find it
at cv. miter.org
cve stands for common vulnerabilities
and exposures and pretty much every
reported vulnerability gets documented
here here and is issued a cve ID number
but what you'll find here as the name
states are common
vulnerabilities I.E vulnerabilities in
thirdparty code apps and libraries that
you use but notice the statement here at
the bottom to specifically look for
vulnerabilities in custom code and
bespoke software and here the DSs adds
more detail about where to find
vulnerabilities in your third-party
software in all of this so far really
focuses on the third party but here in
the last call out box you'll see DSS
showing concern for your proprietary
application logic and this is a really
critical element DSS States for control
over in-house developed software the
organization may receive such
information from external sources and
then they highlight bug Bounty programs
independent investigators and more now
this requirement has big implications
for your apis first first you need to
secure the thirdparty apis that your
applications consume that means keeping
up to date on versions patching is
required monitoring for new
vulnerabilities and second you need to
look at your internally generated code
including anything that's exposed by
apis to find vulnerabilities or logic
flaws authorization gaps or anything
else that can be exploited and you're
not going to find this in any cve
database or Patch Tuesday alert or
anything else flaws in your code are
your own personal zero days and these
vulnerabilities are the types of
vulnerabilities attackers most want to
find the traditional and common
vulnerabilities things like injections
and cross-site scripting are rarely the
cause of major API
breaches your apis expose your
application Logic the good and the bad
and any flaws in your application logic
will also get exposed so it's critical
to one keep up to date on the latest API
attack techniques and two perform
security testing on your applications
regularly that means not once or twice a
year but with every release and make
sure that testing covers your apis and
is providing adequate coverage that
means testing re endpoint across dozens
of attack vectors including logic and
authorization tests now this Probably
sounds a bit daunting and the only way
to achieve this level of continuous
assessment is with automation there are
API optimized testing tools out there to
help
6.3.2 focuses on having an up-to-date
complete and accurate software inventory
specifically your bespoken custom
software as well as any thirdparty code
you're using in your custom applications
the state of goal of this inventory is
to facilitate vulnerability and Patch
management and here in the purpose
section the DSs explicitly calls out
thirdparty libraries and API eyes these
need to be known tracked and managed to
address any vulnerabilities that they
might have actually having an accurate
inventory of your software and apis
isn't just good for security it's
critical to your overall application
governance I've met with many security
teams who claim they have little
awareness of all the apis running in
their organization and this is
undoubtedly true but the fact that
security teams don't have this
information doesn't mean it doesn't
exist so security teams have to partner
with engineering to deal with these API
security concerns the reason why is apis
are fundamentally gateways to your
application functionality and most
vulnerabilities will need to get
addressed inside the app code in
collaboration with the engineering team
we've got whole courses dedicated to API
governance but that's really where
security needs to start governance means
knowing what apis you have but also what
function they provide who has access to
them how they need to be be secured
things like authentication access
controls input validation
Etc and governance also means setting
standards for how your apis are
documented What policies you have for
handling sensitive data when you need
new versions what happens to the old
versions and governance also means apis
get deployed into production in a
standard way where every release goes
through not just functional testing but
security testing too and all apis get
managed in a common platform like an API
Gateway this gives your organization not
just great consistency and operational
efficiency but also enable security what
apis you have how they're being used and
they have to clear the necessary gates
to get into
production for this requirement
organizations have until March 31
2025 one year later than most of the DSs
4.0 and that's likely a reflection of
the challenges organizations have in
even producing an acccurate inv
inventory until then DSS calls this a
best practice which I couldn't agree
more with definitely invest the effort
to produce an inventory but if you're
going to do this then make the most out
of it use this as a driver for better
overall Security in your organization
and better governance across the entire
API life cycle look at your API program
from design to coding to testing to
deployment to really reap the benefits
of better
governance
we're next going to cover 641 and 642
together and you'll see why in a second
this requirement addresses the need to
actively protect public facing web
applications against attacks the purpose
of course is to make sure applications
are resilient against attacks as web
applications are going to be the primary
target for those attacks as DSS States
poorly coded web applications provide an
easy path for attackers to gain access
to to sensitive data and
systems but pay attention to that term
web application many will interpret that
as referring to their web and maybe
mobile user
interfaces when we think of an
application we tend to picture something
you can look at and interact with but
this is not the full scope of your
application you have to look at any
interface human or machine that can
exercise your application and that
includes
apis so the choices DSS provides here
are to either perform a vulnerability
assessment or Implement some kind of
inline automated protection solution if
you go with the vulnerability assessment
route the requirement is to perform the
scan every 12 months or after any major
change to your application the
assessment must be performed by an
organization that specializes in
application security it has to cover all
the threats that we talked about in
6.2.4 you have to rank all the
vulnerabilities you find and correct
them as specified in 631 and then retest
your apps to make sure the
vulnerabilities are remedied now for the
automated protection approach this has
to be installed in front of your web app
running continuously to find and block
any attacks and it must produce audit
logs that can be analyzed later as
needed the most common example of an
automated protection solution is a w a
web application firewall these are
widely used to analyze application layer
traffic and block against known threats
like injections high volume attacks
cross-site scripting Etc an API Gateway
will also provide protection and can
perform things like API input validation
user authentication access controls rate
limiting IP and Geographic white listing
and
more there are API specific runtime
protection Solutions as well that act
like waffs for
apis in terms of timing 641 gives
organizations a choice of approaches
but you have to comply with one or the
other by March 31
2024 now under
642 that option goes away and you must
deploy an automated approach or an
automated technical solution and that is
due by March 31
20125 now although runtime detection and
blocking of active threats is very
appealing the reality is certain attacks
are nearly impossible to detect in real
time a signature-based blocking and
anomaly detection aren't able to
identify every attack some of the most
damaging API attacks we've seen exploit
unique application logic where
unintended flaws exist in the example I
gave earlier with the crypto trading
platform the user exploited a flaw in
the API where they could change their
asset from one type to another this
would be virtually impossible to detect
in any automated way so really the best
practice here is both to do both
automated blocking where possible and to
complement that with Comprehensive
testing to uncover flaws before
attackers find
them section seven of the DSs focuses on
access controls to critical data and
systems I just want to touch on this
section in general and highlight a few
requirements and best practices the
purpose of this whole requirement seven
boils down to who has access to
applications and systems and what can
they do of course this applies to the
underlying infrastructure that supports
your applications the servers containers
databases network devices you have to
make sure access is secure and
controlled
internally at the application layer
though you have to think about all the
functionality the data accessibility the
business flows and your user types for
example a regular user should be able to
access their account balance they should
not be able to see any other users's
data but maybe you have support
Personnel who need to be able to access
any user's information or take that end
user accessing their balance they should
be able to see their balance but not
modify it so what this means is you need
to build a matrix of all functionality
available through your apis and map that
across all of your user types whether
that's an end user support person QA
engineer developer admin Etc and even
map that across your different
environments development testing staging
production it's not enough to do this
analysis at the UI level as we've seen
before while uis provide the to control
user Behavior filter data and manage
what they can do when you take the UI
out of the equation you're left with
individual API endpoints so make sure
you're analyzing access controls at the
API level now let's talk for a second
about authentication versus
authorization you definitely want to set
up policies around API endpoint
authentication and Define those policies
in an API style guide that all your
developers can use for example if an
endpoint is purely informational has no
user data for example an endpoint that
checks where the nearest bank branch is
then maybe you don't need any
authentication on that endpoint but
another endpoint could let a user check
their account balance so you'll want to
authenticate them and maybe even higher
security for performing a transfer like
putting in a two-factor challenge that's
all about confirming that the user is
who they say they are and this can be
managed at the API layer and the best
practice is to centralize all that
access in an API Gateway
but authentication is not the same as
authorization and we've seen many
breaches where an organization
implemented user authentication but fail
to address
authorization let's use another example
there's a popular exercise equipment
vendor that provides an API that is
access to all users in the platform
although the API required users to
authenticate properly to access the
endpoints it did not control which
records they could see so once
authenticated the user could see not
only their own records they could see
anyone else's as well this is more
common than you might imagine the point
is authorization needs to be considered
and defined and then implemented within
the application logic itself not at a
Gateway or other access point lastly
once you've got your access controls
defined and implemented properly you
want to make sure nothing changes and if
something does you know about it here's
where we recommend our back monitoring
I.E continuous Tes of ro-based access
controls to see if any settings get
adjusted so you can be aware and ensure
no control gaps
emerge here's another section I'll cover
at a high level 10.0 log and monitor all
access to system components and card
holder data this section spells out in
detail all the requirements for
collecting logs storing the data in a
central repository and analyzing the
activity records for security and ins
response purposes as the DSs States logs
allow thorough tracking alerting and
Analysis when something does go wrong
determining the cause of a compromise is
difficult if not impossible without
system activity logs now typically
logging is enabled and captured at the
system level I.E all the servers
databases network devices firewalls and
more but logging must also be captured
at the application Level here's where
you'll see the details of user behavior
and be able to find anomalous activity
and to get this level of granularity
your application must first be
instrumented to produce the logs in the
first place make sure your developers
add logging events into their code that
captures all the relevant details who's
performing the action what are they
doing when did it occur from what source
or IP address was the action
successful another great source of
application Level logging is at the API
Gateway these platforms will natively
record all accesses to apis in
individual
endpoints finally be sure to centralize
all this data in a common repository
where your security team can analyze and
detect threats as they
happen and the last section I want to
cover in PCI DSS 4.0 is requirement 11
test security of systems and networks
regularly throughout this course and
across many of the DSS 4.0 sections
we've talked about how important testing
is many of the DSs requirements specify
security objectives with the need to
test to confirm programs are running as
designed to ensure vulnerabilities
aren't appearing and access controls are
set properly section 11.0 formalizes
this need to test for security regularly
and DSs recognizes that vulnerabilities
are being discovered continually by
malicious IND and researchers and being
introduced by new new software system
components processes and bespoken custom
software should be tested frequently to
ensure security controls continue to
reflect a changing environment as you
can see this requirement specifically
refers to bespoken custom software and
the vulnerabilities that your code can
create it also mandates organizations
test applications frequently to ensure
no vulnerabilities go undiscovered as
we've discussed throughout this course
application testing cannot be limited to
I alone public facing applications rely
on public facing apis and these are ripe
targets for attackers so your testing
programs must include apis and should be
automated to ensure complete coverage of
every API endpoint simulate attacks
across all of the oos top 10 categories
and more and run in a continuous manner
recognizing that modern organizations
update code monthly weekly and even
daily so make sure your testing keeps
up
okay we've covered a lot of ground here
and have examined how organizations need
to address API security concerns to stay
compliant with PCI DSS 4.0 so let's
bring it all together and summarize what
the requirements are some of the best
practices for not only complying with
the standard but in elevating your
organization security posture and we'll
wrap it up with a list of dues and
don'ts first let's summarize the various
sections of DSs 4.0 and what they mean
for
apis starting with
2.2.7 this requires secure access to
admin consoles including encryption of
all Communications make sure you're
looking at API access to consoles as
well and not only encrypting the
communication but controlling access to
those
endpoints 6.0 is the core of DSs 4.0
with respect to securing payment related
applications we spent a lot of time
looking at many different subsections of
requirement six the key to remember here
is that with DSS 4.0 apis are 100% in
scope now all your bspoke and custom
software the code you write to power
your organization's unique offerings is
powered by apis and those apis need to
be secured as much or even more than
your classic web and mobile applications
the subsections in requirement 6 get
more specific about securing your custom
applications 621 focuses on secure
software development and requires
Engineers to be aware of API security
and vulnerability risks to ensure code
is free of flaws that can be exploited
DSS recommends integrating as far left
as possible to find vulnerabilities
before they reach
production 622 sets requirements for
annual training of developers apis have
unique attack patterns so it's critical
that your developers understand what
these look like and how to create more
secure
applications 623 requires organizations
to review and test code for security
flaws
here DSS highlights how attackers are
targeting your custom code via the apis
and looking to find an exploit logic
vulnerabilities 624 covers a wide range
of well-known application attack types
and mirrors closely the threats listed
in the oosp application in API security
top 10 lists this section rightly calls
out API specifically and highlights
attacks on business logic and
manipulation of apis the point being
your vulnerability Discovery efforts
need to cover apis not just
uis 631 calls on organizations to
implement vulnerability Management
Programs it's important to focus on the
vulnerabilities that are likely to cause
the most damage and while injections and
cross-site scripting are legitimate
vulnerabilities and you absolutely need
to test and fix these flaws these really
are the cause of major breaches what we
see regularly are logic flaws weak
authentication and authorization gaps
these are the vulnerabilities you need
to test for especially at the API level
632 requires organizations to develop
and maintain an accurate and up-to-date
inventory of all custom software this
must include your apis having an
accurate inventory is really part of a
solid application governance program
where you standardize how apis get
created set security policies that are
implemented consistently and all apis
get tested and deployed in a common way
641 gives organizations an opt to
perform either periodic vulnerability
assessments or Implement runtime attack
detection and blocking the option goes
away in 2025 when all PCI covered
entities must enforce active detection
and blocking just be aware that not all
threats can be detected in real time
there's no magic firewall that will
protect against all threats and in fact
frequently the most damaging exploits
aren't detectable so you need to keep up
testing and detection of vulnerabilities
and then fix this in the
code 7.0 requires strong access controls
here you need to examine the entire
infrastructure and application stag and
look at what users can access and what
they can see it's important to review
these controls down to the individual
API endpoint level to make sure there
aren't any access gaps and definitely
Implement continuous testing to uncover
and alert on any changes in Access
permissions 10.0 requires organizations
to capture logs from all systems
involved in payment processing this is
critical to detect threats and perform
root cause analysis make sure you're
capturing user activity logs on apis as
well and this is best accomplished with
an API Gateway and 11.0 calls on
organizations to perform regular testing
of their custom software so make sure
that includes all of your apis as
well all right as we wrap up this course
let's touch on some of the core best
practices not just to comply with PCI
but to run a more efficient and
effective API security program we'll
start with governance API security is
not really something you can bolt on you
want to integrate security into the
entire application life cycle from
design to product to retirement creating
a culture of security throughout your
organization this starts with putting
time and effort into defining your API
policies how your API get used who can
use them what they can do then defining
your standards what API should look like
how do they get created and then
standardizing your processes how do apis
move from development through qway and
into production in a consistent manner
it's highly recommended that you
centralize all your apis in a common
platform something like an API Gateway
or a Marketplace this will let you
manage apis consistently Define common
policies and give you a central source
for auditing and logging user behavior
and make sure all your apis only go into
production having passed the required
Gates including documentation testing
security audit and so forth our next
best practice focuses on how to create a
culture of security within the
engineering and development
organizations we've hosted many
roundtables with cyber security leaders
and noticed a common theme the cesos
uniformly agreed on the need to
integrate security into the development
team and one of the best ways to create
that security awareness was to embed
security Champions right into those
teams as we've discussed especially with
applications and apis development shares
the responsibility for security as most
vulnerabilities will require Dev
involvement to remediate security
Champions are security Savvy Personnel
who can work and operate directly within
the development organization providing
insights best practices answering
questions and so
forth number three on our best practices
list is actually straight out of the DSs
document providing API security training
to all relevant EMP employees and this
should include any developers creating
apis any API product owners and Ops
teams as we've seen apis face new and
different types of attacks so make sure
the training covers API specific threats
the oasp API security top 10 and best
practices for keeping API secure we've
got a great course at appc University
called API security fundamentals it
covers everything I just mentioned and
can even be deployed in an internal
learning management system in our last
best practice here focuses on testing
apis expose so much application
functionality and it's more critical
than ever to really pressure test that
functionality to make sure your apps
can't be abused this means testing every
single API endpoint across all kinds of
attack types everything you see in the
oos top 10 and examine your app logic to
look for any flaws or gaps that can be
exploit it and you need to do this with
automation Implement a testing program
that will run automatically create the
the test coverage you need and run
against every release to find
vulnerabilities before they get to
production I like to wrap up my courses
with some really tactical do's and
don'ts that you can take back and
Implement right away as we've mentioned
a number of times do educate your
development team and API owners on API
risks they're under attack and the
threats are different than what our web
apps have seen do integrate security
into the dev process make sure Engineers
understand how to code more resilient
apis and test for vulnerabilities ahead
of production do build communication
between security and development the Gap
here is way too big way too often both
teams need to collaborate to keep API
secure do mandate documentation on all
apis this feels like one that shouldn't
be needed but far too many apis are not
documented underdocumented or not
updated documentation helps Drive
consistency reusability integration and
also
security don't treat internal apis as
inherently secure they may be harder to
find but attackers are pretty clever and
we've seen many internal apis get
accessed in unexpected ways do
centralize API management and control in
something like a Gateway many
organizations end up using multiple
gateways which is fine just use some
platform to manage all your apis in a
consistent
way don't rely exclusively on manual
security testing a once or twice a year
penetration test will not keep up with
the pace of your code changes and it
won't give you the breadth of coverage
considering how many endpoints you have
and the attack types you need to
simulate which leads to our next item do
automate testing integrate your testing
with your cicd pipeline make sure every
release gets tested before they go live
don't filter data in the UI this is one
I can't stress enough if your app
returns all the fields of a record and
you rely on the UI to filter out the
sensitive stuff then all an attacker
needs to do is go around the UI and call
the API directly and get the raw
unfiltered
data do take time to carefully Define
API standards This falls under the
governance umbrella it's really
important to have a well defined thought
out set of API standards and policies
this will Aid your entire API life cycle
including security and
compliance do pressure test your apis
for logic flaws these are nearly
impossible to detect in real time so
make sure you test your apis in ways
they're not meant to be used to find
these flaws do use runtime protection to
block well-known attacks this is
mandated in PCI and is a best practice
so use a web application firewall or
other device to block volumetric attacks
injections and others but don't expect
the firewall to prevent all threats some
are going to get through so make sure
you're finding those vulnerabilities
especially logic vulnerabilities through
testing before for production and
finally do train your API teams on the
oosp API security top 10 this is the
industry standard on API risks for a
good reason and you definitely want your
developers to understand the
threats that wraps up the API security
for PCI compliance course
congratulations on making it all the way
through I hope you enjoyed the course
we'll be sending you a certificate of
completion and badge to recognize your
accomplishment really appreciate you
taking the time for this course and I
invite you to check out our other
courses at appc university.com I'd love
to hear from you if you've got any
feedback suggestions or just want to
connect for any other reason you can
find me on LinkedIn and you're welcome
to email me directly thanks again and I
hope to see you in another course
soon okay that wraps up the API security
for PCI compliance course hope you
enjoyed it if you'd like to earn a badge
and certificate for this course please
enroll at Appy university.com
take the quizzes and we'll be happy to
issue your sht while you're there be
sure to check out our other courses
including API pen testing API security
fundamentals and more we also host many
webinars with API experts across
Industries disciplines and geographies
you'll see these listed on our website
and on our YouTube Channel Please
Subscribe thanks for watching and hope
to see you again
soon